I bet that you have a almost religious  like faith in the power of the free  market to set its own uh agendas and  regulations and limitations and that if  you just leave it alone it will take  care of it'll take care I used to until  I study China okay I used to until I  study China because when I study China  and I realized in the 80s they only had  four law schools and it was a doggy dog  type of an environment you start  realizing you need Law and Order and  some regulation it's the over regulation  I have a challenge with where the bigger  companies use lobbyists and politicians  that are broke to buy them to create  laws to make it tougher for the smaller  guy to compete with them